[Music]
well the big blue building soaring on
the las vegas strip for a long time is
coming back to life
mariette has been announcing on their
website that the former fountain blue
will soon become a jw marriott within a
couple of years
joe muller live in the strip with the
changes now expected hi joe
hey there brian well whether you're
walking on the strip or you're driving
around town it's hard to miss the
giant blue building you see behind us
here come 2023 this
the north end of the strip here will
really be bustling you have the brand
new convention center right next door
to that building and then just across
the street from us here you also have
resorts world with
which also just opened i love vegas
i think it's pretty sad for years the
big blue building also known as the
fountain blue has remained vacant
ghostly we were just talking about as we
walked by and it looks kind of rusty and
old i think it's a big eyesore
it was supposed to open in 2009 but
instead went bankrupt that year
the result of the financial crisis i'm
so curious as to find out what
it really is going to end up being the
property had different owners over the
years and different names the most
recent
the drew now according to the marriott
the operators will be jw marriott
featuring 3 700 rooms a casino and a
bridge to the new convention center
the new ownership has the capacity with
their
financial partners to actually put this
together this time
commercial real estate agent mike mixer
is optimistic jw merritt's a top tier
brand i think they're going to bring the
addition which is another higher end
brand within the marriott chain
following the opening of resorts world
and chatter of other potential projects
he says this could draw more people
north
we've got recent news now that perhaps
the a's baseball organization might be
looking at the
phil ruffin property which is adjacent
to circus circus
and if jackie robinson puts together his
all-nets
resort basketball arena people say a
well-known brand
could be good i have points i can use
now back out here live the expected
completion date on this is the end of
2023 we also did reach out to marriott
and other parties involved to find out
when
construction might start up again in
this building but we have yet to hear
back
reporting live on the las vegas strip
joe muller 8 news now